really good game this one and now deadly
threat on the board deadly bring the
queen and blocking the the black screen
route to the corner so he's running
that that didn't work
why doesn't it work um
bishop rick takes bishop
too
what's happening
this one is super complicated right now
uh white has just taken a pawn and
black's king cannot run because now the
knight is under fire and actually
there's it done there's some huge
threats white's queen is trying to come
up to the top of the board and then the
black rock in the corner would be taken
you can check you can check
you can check take the knight you've got
the h pawn i think this has happened
before magnus even though the computer
says he's winning as soon as he gets bit
of pressure
he he doesn't find the right defense
could is jan winning now
i think he might be winning also look
that white h pawn harry might decide
this game might become a queen doesn't
does that really surprise you ever since
you arrived simon that keeps happening
shouldn't really surprise you but it
doesn't look that magnus is reacting to
this it looks like jan has been reacting
to this magnus making a move with uh
with 50 seconds left on the clock i
think he just panicked maybe because of
the clock situation he had to make a
hasty decision and it just wasn't the
right one i think maybe the black king
could have run in a different way and uh
now this check clears the path for that
yh pawn to continue matching up the
board wow still not easy despite
uh i mean things are switching and
changing and twists and turns um i think
one slip and it might go back in black's
favor so white has to be careful now but
harry does advance and this is is now
back to being equal again this is this
is like very human game